on me dit souvent tu arrêtes pas de
critiquer dans tes vidéos c'est à dire
que tu m as rien non non j'aime plein de
trucs à j'aime bien les le nom là je
déteste le rideau de douche qui te colle
quand je déteste la pub qui s'élance
dans un thé anglais mais tu sais pas
lequel tu sors je vais te trouver où tu
es tu te caches où julien je déteste les
capsules de canettes qui pète je déteste
les interrupteurs à l'extérieur des
toilettes fort appuyer sur le bouton
s'il vous plaît pourquoi on prend peu on
peut techniquement les mettre à
l'intérieur
alors pourquoi les mettre là où on peut
te faire chier je déteste travailler sur
un logiciel pendant des heures avant
qu'ils plantent et bien sûr tu n'as pas
sauvegardés non non non non non non je
déteste quand j'attends un coup de fil
important et comme il vient pas je
prends une douche et bien sûr c'est à ce
moment là qu'on m'appelle je déteste la
coupe de cheveux après avoir porté un
casque essayer de pécho comme ça tu veux
sortir avec moi je déteste quand tu
attends qu une vidéo youtube se chargent
tu la mets en plein écran et ça doit
recharger qui est le mec chez youtube
qui a pensé à cette fonctionnalité un
mec qui n'a pas free visiblement je
déteste quand je comprends pas l'ironie
mais qui hier soir j'ai vu le dernier
twilight mais c'est un truc d'un malade
c'est une bombe ce truc c'est un [ __ ]
de sedoc votre moi aussi j'ai adoré
quand j'en ai eu
mais c'est une blague ouais ouais ça que
la fin était un peu non tout chez ta
mère je déteste quand je parle à
quelqu'un sur facebook
je sais qu'il a vu mon message mais il
ne me répond pas
la solitude je déteste les gens qui
laissent leurs doigts en passant les
pages oui oui on regarde les stars chez
kana je déteste quand un mec room par
son facebook sans faire exprès je clique
sur sa fenêtre
du coup il sait que j'ai lu son message
je déteste quand on m'appelle quand j'ai
mon téléphone dans les mains du coup je
suis obligé d'attendre quelques
sonneries avant de décrocher
ouais mais pas faire le mec sans amis
qui décrochent dès qu'on l'appelle à
l'eau un ami ouais tu veux qu'on passe
un truc on va jouer ensemble je déteste
quand un de mes voisins ne m'attends pas
en prenant l'ascenseur je déteste
recevoir un sms est en fait non c'était
un mec à côté de moi la solitude le
retour je déteste les fautes
d'orthographe dans les sous titres de
série les mecs font des sous titres de
série toutes les semaines mais n'ont
jamais ouvert un bescherelle
bon j'avoue je déteste prendre
l'ascenseur avec quelqu'un
je déteste parler à quelqu'un je fous tu
as vu ce soir il ya un machisme dans ses
tablettes qui en fait était au téléphone
donc quand je pourrais savoir que
c'était un ami un mois je déteste quand
quelqu'un est en train de mesquer sur
facebook puis il efface que voulais tu
me dire je suis pas digne de ton message
c'est ça tu es au dessus des tout eu des
gens je veux savoir
j'ai besoin de savoir je déteste quand
on lèche que couteau avant de le
remettre dans le pot de nutella
tiens je déteste quand on ouvre à pot de
nutella et qu'il reste de l'aluminium
sur les bords ça nous donne envie de
toujours comme ça oui je suis un malade
mental je déteste quand je tue quelqu'un
et je sais pas vous cacher le corps ça
m'énerve quand c'est mauvais ça
[Musique]
et toi tu détestes quoi
je déteste de vidéos de ce preneur parce
que ça devenait commercial